a lot of people in southern nevada
having a difficult time keeping food on
the table during the pandemic
three square food bank is doing an
incredible job helping
individuals and families doing what they
can findley automotive
is a tremendous supporter of three
square tyler quarter cfo
of finley is here to talk about how
everybody can help you guys have been
helping out three square for some time
now
yeah so we've been uh pretty involved
with three square and
and uh really you know they're they're
our only food bank in southern nevada
and it's uh it's i don't know if people
realize that during the pandemic it's
had a tremendous impact on
what they call food insecurity in in
southern nevada and they think that
one out of uh every five people now is
food insecure which means that they
don't have the resources to know
for sure where their next meal is coming
from and so that's a tremendous problem
and that's one that three square is out
to uh to try to help
fix and we want to support him in that
cost for sure what's amazing and i'm so
impressed by so many things about three
square
is how far one dollar can go one donated
dollar
yeah so that's you know they they think
that they can feed
they can provide three meals for every
dollar and that's because they have
you know they have a lot of supporters
that give them uh uh
you know food donations but also because
their buying power
is so tremendous and so it's much more
efficient to give them a dollar that it
is to give them
you know to go to a food drive and
donate cans of food or something because
they can make better use of the dollars
and help feed more people that are in
need uh so yeah
the financial assistance uh whatever
they get every dollar makes a big
difference
and money's tight for a lot of people
right now so of course
a little bit of money can go a long way
with three square there are other ways
for people to get involved and to help
out as well
yeah so what you know three square like
everyone had to adapt their business a
little bit so now they've got off-site
distribution centers where people you
know drive through
and and walk in pantries where people
can get food and that's
really important right now if you
especially think about school-age
children a lot of
school children were getting their main
meals of the day
through the fact that they were going to
school and now that the schools aren't
meeting in person
there's an awful lot of children that
are food insecure and so having all
these distribution sites around
is important and what three threesquare
can use is they can use some volunteers
at these uh distribution centers and and
so there's information on three squares
website as to where all the locations
are for the distribution centers but
also how you can get involved and maybe
besides making financial donations
become a volunteer
and help them get the food to where it
needs to get tyler as always great
information and you guys do such good
work with so many non-profits including
three square thanks so much for joining
us today
great talking to you thanks all right we
want to thank findlay automotive group
for being one of our community pride
partners